vedo facce preoccupate
buongiorno a tutti intanto grazie per la
straordinaria opportunità di potervi
raccontare che cosa facciamo ma
soprattutto delle meravigliose cose che
vediamo ogni giorno
oggi vi parlerò del dell'approccio del
metodo che utilizziamo con i ragazzi con
migliaia di ragazzi ogni anno ormai
siamo una grande squadra che lo fa è un
approccio che vede l'elemento
sperimentale l'elemento pratico al
centro dell'esperienza perché abbiamo
scoperto e poi parleremo che grazie
all'elemento touch nel senso proprio
pratico è possibile aumentare la
capacità del pensiero e la capacità
dell'immaginazione
ma proprio perché vogliamo mettere
l'esperimento al centro
parto subito con un esperimento che vi
porto un po nelle le aule che ogni
giorno su cui ogni giorno andiamo e vi
faccio vedere alcuni alcuni elementi
vedo vedo qualche faccia preoccupata
qualcuno curioso di solito espressione
che abbiamo è è questa solitamente
magari i ragazzi sono un po meno
preoccupati ma c'è curiosità c'è stupore
e meraviglia ma appunto timore in realtà
questo è azoto si è un po freddo forse
avete avuto un progetto dei veri è però
e azoto oltre 70 per cento dell'area che
stiamo respirando è formata dal
gabbiotto
ma allora perché abbiamo paura perché
abbiamo timore perché non ne abbiamo
esperienza vedete quando noi siamo
entrati entriamo nelle nelle scuole
spesso manca una struttura che sia in
grado di far fare i ragazzi esperienze
che abbiamo docenti che gridano a gran
voce la necessità di strumentazione
attività di conoscenze su questo settore
perché ci sono
competenze che non possono essere
demandate ad un manuale se il suo
cartaceo o digitale ma devono essere
toccate con mano un bambino impara a
correre però prima di imparare a correre
impara a camminare e lo fa per tentativi
non leggendo delle istruzioni e concetti
contenuti che utilizzano questo
approccio sono molti ma andando dalle
scuole
abbiamo anche imparato un'altra cosa che
non stavamo parlando solo con i docenti
ne stavamo parlando con i genitori con
gli studenti gli insegnanti dirigenti i
nonni in una rete estremamente fitta e
correlata la quale non solo si comunica
che cosa viene nelle classi ma comunica
l'emozione quando si tratta di attività
sperimentali e voglio dimostrarlo come
un post che abbiamo raccolto qualche
giorno fa perché insomma quando the peak
roncale cha ha contattato sono stato un
punto d'orgoglio e noi abbiamo iniziato
condividerlo nei nostri social e così la
condivisione a condivisione è finit
diciamo in un gruppo genitori era una
mamma che aveva avuto la figlia che
lavato un'esperienza pratica dice ma
come questi qua adesso vanno là si
ritengono loro probabilmente e noi nella
nostra scuola
ditemi cosa devo fare li dobbiamo avere
dobbiamo avere questo tipo di attività
qui se devo vendere torte vendo torte ma
quando abbiamo letto questo post è
ovviamente abbiamo detto wow questo
genitore mite la stessa passione che ci
mettiamo le attività sperimentali che
mettono i ragazzi nelle attività
sperimentali quindi la rete è veramente
città e riesce a trasmettere anche
questa componente di di emozione di
scoperta di curiosità ma allora c'è
posto ci siamo posti una domanda ma cosa
che realmente facciamo cos'è che
concretamente riusciamo a fare con
questa attività pratica e sperimentale
beh lo voglio fare voglio voglio
raccontarvelo con andrea
un bambino ragazzino otto anni questa è
la vera che ti è successo a due anni fa
e andrea in terza elementare
siamo in una mostra pratica sperimentare
siamo con lui e la sua classe davanti a
questo esperimento che è formato da
quattro carrucole ogni sotto ogni
carrucola ci sono dieci chili
nella prima è collegata con una corda la
seconda con due la terza con train e la
quarta con quattro li facciamo provare
giocano provano poi ragioniamo perché
l'approccio non è solo l'esperimento
fine a se stesso e dall'esperimento poi
ragionare e solitamente in terza
elementare chiedo quanto fa dieci chili
diviso due corde e gli rispondono poi kg
10 diviso 4 c'è insomma un po di
difficoltà ma fanno solo che sono stanco
e tutto il giorno anche spiego e davanti
a me ho fissato con la carrucola con le
tre corde e dico 10 diviso tra le vedo
subito nel panico dicono no scusate non
ho fatto una domanda solo che vedo
andrea ho scoperto ovviamente dopo come
si chiamava vedo andare a che fa così e
poi torna indietro e non dice niente
lo vedo intuisco qualcosa e dico ma
dimmi dimmi stesso timore paura un po
come l'azoto di prima fa no no no no
dimmi io sbaglio tantissimo prova allora
andrea buffa non so se si può
è un po come se facesse 3 contanti tre
che non finiscono più dei minimi si è
accapponata la pelle e guardo
l'insegnante l'insegnante gennaro non ho
fatto niente
il periodo è una cosa bella signora e ha
scoperto davanti a noi grazie alla a me
questo metodo pratico ha scoperto i
numeri periodici ha scoperto l'infinito
ma non solo domani andrea dovrà
risolvere un problema dovrà trovare una
soluzione domanda dovrà essere il nuovo
attivo
io credo che grazie a queste esperienze
andrea abbia la possibilità di avere un
pensiero un po più grande ed immaginaria
un po di più
vedete l'immaginazione è finita è
limitata ma può aumentare
l'immaginazione è un muscolo e come
tutti i muscoli può essere allenato con
il giusto approccio
dovessimo imparare a nuotare potremo
leggere tutti i manuali che vogliamo ma
dobbiamo entrare nell'acqua
non ci sono altre vie lo stesso succede
con tantissimi con tantissimi elementi
ma non è solo una questione di concetto
è anche una questione biologica e questo
è anche una questione biologica il colle
toma cioè l'insieme delle relazioni che
ci sono nei neuroni e influenzato
dall'ambiente esterno
e ciò che sentiamo vediamo ciò che
pensiamo che siamo in grado di pensare e
figlio anche delle esperienze che noi
facciamo è che abbiamo fatto e il tipo
di esperienze quindi c'è un'influenza
anche biologica estremamente concreta ma
ve lo voglio raccontare con anna
un'altra ragazzina di 10 anni anna con
anna parliamo di colori con anna che ha
studiato come funzionano i colori a
scuola diciamo che abbiamo
abbiamo qui un liquido abbiamo una cosa
trasparente ma in realtà ne abbiamo tre
trasparenti ma se io mescolo due cose
trasparenti cosa fa cosa succede ora chi
pensa ragione va bene solo abbia visto
come funzionano i colori trasparenti più
trasparente fa trasparente
speriamo allora con ma proviamo e
vediamo cosa succede allora trasparente
più trasparente può notare trasparente
può fare un colore estremamente acceso
allora anna dice ma è straordinario e di
così
extra ordinario e fuori dall'ordinario
non mi avevi avuto esperienza ma a loro
dico facciamo qualche ragionamento più
proviamo e se avesse aggiungo un'altra
cosa trasparente e beh sarà un po
diluita magari si schiarisce un po
proviamo anna sperimentiamo allora
vediamo che cosa succede è quello che
succede
e che ritorna completamente trasparente
allora mi dice ma allora gli insegnanti
mi ha detto una cosa sbagliata sui
colori no non ci ha detto una cosa
sbagliata e che ci siano più possibilità
ora facciamo crescere anna facciamola
diventare grande adulta consumatrice
facciamola andare davanti nostro di una
confezione in cui ci sono scritte cose
come coloranti o sbiancanti e
chiediamoci se queste esperienze possono
influenzare la capacità di scelta
la la libertà con cui anna si può
muovere
ecco vedete noi crediamo che per
aumentare la capacità di pensiero
l'immaginazione per essere innovativi
non possiamo usare sempre gli stessi
colori
dobbiamo aumentare il numero di colori
io credo che quello che facciamo con le
attività pratiche sperimentali sia
questo aumentare il numero di colori
grazie